abortion was on the ballot this was a
referendum and the people voted to
enshrine the license to murder children
at essentially any point in pregnancy in
the Ohio state constitution it's called
issue one it changes the State
Constitution and takes precedence over
laws passed by the state legislature so
it might well be irreversible the only
way that it could be reversed is by a
ballot measure another ballot measure to
reverse it pro-abortion groups did a
great job on this bot measure because
they framed the the vote as a matter of
Freedom as a matter of of uh shrinking
the regulations of the government where
was the
pro-life
referendum where where were the
conservative groups the Republican
groups out there who were putting their
own ballot initiative out to say we're
going to enshrine life in the State Ohio
State Constitution or in any other state